manifestation aujourd'hui en espagne
après une troisième nuit de violences à
l'origine de ces heurts la condamnation
à deux ans et demi de prison du rappeur
pablo hazell mardi en cause notamment le
fait qu'il ait publié des tweets visant
la monarchie et les forces de l'ordre
depuis des milliers de manifestants
défilent dans les rues de madrid et de
barcelone en catalogne une quinzaine de
personnes a été arrêtée le gouvernement
je cite s'opposera à toute forme de
violence déclaration ce matin du premier
ministre pedro sanchez
il n'y a pas d'exception à la règle
il n'y a pas de cause ni de lieu ni de
situations qui puissent justifier le
recours à la violence
aucune précisément parce que la violence
n'est pas une liberté
c'est une atteinte à la liberté des
autres la violence est une attaque
contre la démocratie et par conséquent
le gouvernement espagnol s'opposera à
toute forme de violence et garantira la
sécurité des citoyens la démocratie
protège la liberté de manifestation
la liberté d'expression et même
l'expression des pensées les plus
méprisables et absurde mais la
démocratie nous protégera jamais la
violence h en parallèle les
revendications semblent désormais
dépassé le seul cas du jeune rappeur
arrêté on écoute son avocat n'étaient
pas ici dans ce pays il est très facile
d'utiliser le terme de glorification du
terrorisme pour persécuter la dissidence
politique
c'est l'un des pays où beaucoup
d'artistes ont été condamnés à des
peines de prison
ce qui n'est pas acceptable nous avons
d'autres problèmes politiques et sociaux
dans le contexte de la pandémie la
récession économique est une question
cruciale puisque les jeunes n'ont aucun
avenir et l'offre orange est faux tout
leur deck l'état et puissant et il a
recours à de nombreux types de violence
pour se protéger c'est une violence
systémique et quotidiennes contre ceux
qui ont perdu leurs maisons qui n'ont
pas de maison faute de revenus les gens
ne sont pas contents de cette violence
[Musique]